[Musique]
l'aviso routière c'est ça
salut brut dès 6h50 on est à
saint-andré-de-cubzac dans les 33 et là
je vais commencer ma journée en tant qu
routière les livres et donc la mort sont
lisses que j'ai changé il hier et
ensuite je crois en direction cahors
mais je ne sais pas où je vais c'est ma
maison
je passe ma vie dedans quoi
c'est pas bien grand
on va payer
bon ben là je vais pouvoir des bâches et
m'a sauvé
la vie d'une routière c'est à se lever
le matin tôt
se préparer rapidement quand même et
c'est parti pour let's go sur la route
jusqu'à son client après dans livre on
recharge on et puis bon ça s'arrête pour
la nuit
ça fait quatre ans que j'exerce je suis
devenu routière parce que mon père est
également routier donc du coup il m'a
transmis la passion des camions quand
j'étais petit je partais tout le temps
en camion avec lui pendant les vacances
scolaires et c'est là où j'ai vraiment
pris goût au métier
c'est la boîte à outils et le petit
tabouret
c'est un peu quand même
je vais signer les papiers et c'est bon
donc je projet je sus que je prends le
jurassien cahors
alors là c'est mon lit voilà c'est là où
je louche d'or donc j'ai essayer
d'aménager ça un petit peu se sont un
peu cocooning avec des petits coussins
petit plaide voilà est donc en hausse et
mon armoire en fait c'est là où je
fourre tout mais affaires bat pour la
semaine j'ai un peu la boule mes papiers
mon casque et là bas des produits pour
faire le ménage
pour avoir une vie de famille en étant
routier c'est assez compliqué parce que
on est là que le week end le fait d'être
une femme routière c'est pas toujours
évident quand même encore pas mal de
réflexions sexistes je vais arriver un
endroit où c'est une manoeuvre un petit
peu délicate
tout de suite
ça va tu sait le manier tonton camion tu
vas réussir à se garer bah oui puis même
sûrement mieux que 80% des chauffeurs
mais oui
ça a évolué j'essaie de faire évoluer
justement les mentalités justement
montrant que une femme peut être
féminine et être entière en même temps
je parle beaucoup avec deux trous tiers
parce que comme ça on peut échanger sur
notre expérience et on s'entraide entre
nous
là je regarde tous les villages où je
vais devoir passer
voir si ça va passer mon camion ses 16
mètres cinquante de long et je peux être
chargé jusqu'à 44 tonnes c'est quand
même un gros bébé ça passe pas partout
donc oui je me fais régulièrement des
peurs à me dire
là ça va pas passer mon au final ça
passe donc là je viens de m'arrêter pour
pouvoir faire la coupure ce que j'ai
fait quatre heures trente de conduite
donc 4 h 30 de conduite je dois faire
quarante cinq minutes de pause
c'est important de manger
la soie life on leur pose soit vous
allez vous dormir là moi j'ai de la
chance ce soir laurence
quand j'ai fini ma journée bas je
cherche un parking
soit j'essaie de prendre ma douche
en fin d'après midi sur une station
service
et je m'arrête pas au bord d'une route
sur un parking isolé
ou sinon je vais dans les resto routier
comportement ait histoire souvent ça va
mal et jusqu'où ira ce sont mes disques
disque d'or au disque de pâte 80 cents
et j'aime vraiment elle le fait d'être
d'être salée pouvoir parce que je veux
si je veux hurler dans le camion me
prend me prendre pour beyoncé je le fais
quoi alors qu'au final je casse les
oreilles mais
personne l'entente
[Musique]
là tous y vont dormir ou six qui ont
trempé d'affaires aux 45 d'affaires
c'est bon en fin de journée
[Musique]
non je n'en peux plus je suis en bout du
rouleau j'ai envie de rentrer me faut
pas s'en vanter et terminer mon soir